if you're looking for ways to do hard
things
choose a life of adventure and empower
people then this video is for you you
know we all have adversity in our lives
you can choose a life of ease and
comfort or you can choose a life of
service and adventure every time you
figure out some way of providing tools
and services that empower other people
to deploy their creativity you're really
onto something need motivation watch it
top ten don't believe nation what's up
it's Ivan my why nor disbelieve and I
believe in you I believe in that amazing
thing you have inside you that I want to
see burst out into the world so let's
get your motivation to attend and have
you believing in you grab a snack and
chew on today's lessons from a man who
went from quitting his high paying job
in New York to driving across the
country to Seattle and writing his
business plan for a new company called
Amazon along the way and made him the
richest man in the world
it's Jeff Bezos and here's my take on
his top 10 rose to success vol 3 enjoy
so let's take things off with rule
number one experiment more you cannot
invent and pioneer if you cannot accept
failure its you to invent you need to
experiment and if it's if you know in
advance that it's going to work it is
not an experiment and so that's a very
important thing you know it's these
they're inseparable twins failure and
invention so you have to be willing to
do that
it's embarrassing to fail you know it's
always embarrassing to fail but you have
to say no that's not how this works if I
said to you you have a 10% chance of a
with a particular decision a 10% chance
of a 100x return you should take that
bet every time but you're still gonna be
wrong nine out of ten times and it's
gonna feel bad nine out of ten times and
in in in with technology the outcomes
the results can be very long tailed they
it's very at the payoff is can be very
asymmetric which is why you should do so
much experimentation you know everybody
knows that if you swing for the fences
you hit more home runs but you also
strike out more but with the baseball
that analogy doesn't go far enough
because with baseball no matter how well
you connect with the ball you can only
get four runs the success is capped at
four runs but in business every once in
a while you step up to the plate you hit
the ball so hard you get a thousand runs
and so when that when you have that kind
of asymmetric payoff and you know one
app one app back and get you a thousand
runs it encourages you to experiment
more it's the right business decision to
experiment more it's also better for
your customers customers like the
successful experiments I love this point
as leadoff and I think you have to get
used to experiencing more and feeling
more and if you're in an environment
where failure is shunned where your
parents and your friends and the people
around you are going to laugh at you and
that's just the environment that you're
in the failure sucks and feels a
reflection on you then I strongly
encourage you to start to share
what you consume watch more videos like
this I guarantee you if you watched a
video a day of people like this talking
your perspective affiliate will change
and so will you and you'll take more
experiments you'll take more bets
and then you'll start to win let's move
on the rule number two choose to do hard
things you know we all have adversity in
our lives yeah I would I would I doubt
if you really you know if you know
somebody any friend or anybody that you
talk to there's no lack of adversity and
the and by the way that's good because
it's what teaches us how to get back up
you fall down you get back up it always
happens and you know you get certain
gifts in life and you want to take
advantage of those but you like it's my
advice on adversity and success would be
to be proud not of your gifts but of
your hard work and your choices so you
know you may be the kinds of gifts you
get like you know you might be really
good at math it might be really easy for
you that's a kind of gift but practicing
that math and taking it to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat that's a choice
you can't really be proud of your gifts
because they were given to you you can
be grateful for them and thankful for
them and but your choices you choose to
work hard you choose to do hard things
those are choices that you can be proud
of this is a fantastic point and one
that I think people are always working
on there's always something harder that
you can work on there's always something
bigger that you can work towards there's
always a greater impact that you can
have so the things that I found hard
five years ago like making a youtube
video they're not hard for me anymore
right they're easy but then to do the
next thing and the next thing and the
next thing is constantly harder and I
think having people videos resources in
your life that push you constantly to
try to do harder and harder and harder
and harder things is where your
Venus will come from is where your
growth will come from and where
ultimately you're successful coming from
so it's a great point I love it let's
move on the rule number three be an
inventor if you want to be an inventor
of any kind of venting a new you know a
new service offering for customers or a
new product or anything the being an
inventor requires because the world is
so complicated you have to be a domain
expert I mean in a way even if even if
you're not the beginning you have to
learn learn learn learn learn enough so
to become a domain expert but the danger
is once you've become a domain expert
you can be trapped by that knowledge and
so inventors have this paradoxical
ability to have that you know 10,000
hours of practice and be a real domain
expert and have that beginner's mind
have that that look at it freshly even
though they know so much about the
domain and that's the key to inventing
you have to have both and I think that
is intentional I think all of us have
that inside of us and we could all do it
but you have to be intentional about it
you have to say yeah I am going to
become an expert and I'm gonna keep my
beginner's mind so I think this is where
it's really helpful to have multiple
interests so yes you're the domain
expert I love YouTube I'm all-in on
YouTube I know YouTube inside-out in
most cases and I have other interests I
love entrepreneurship I love salsa
dancing I like League of Legends I have
a dog I have a wife all of these things
are different part of me and as I am in
my relationship talking to Nina I get
ideas for my youtube channel as I'm
meeting an entrepreneur I get another
idea for my youtube channel so going all
in on one thing and being that expert
but still have another interest where
you can pull and learn from and see how
things are doing in that other industry
and how it might apply to yours I think
is really really really important the
reason why it's so important is because
a lot of the inventions are really just
pulling something that works in nature
or works in a different industry and
applying it to yours and poof you've
created something brand new let's jump
to rule number four go step by step so
your question is you know did I kind of
anticipate what would happen over the
last 22 years at Amazon and the answer
is god no so you know
Amazon started as a very small company
it was me and a few other people I was
driving all the packages to the post
office myself in my 1987 Chevy Blazer
and when I raised money for Amazon I had
to raise a million dollars which I
raised from 22 different investors
$50,000 each they got 20% of the company
for for the million dollars and it was a
40 people told me no so I did take 60
meetings to get 20 s's the first
question was always what's the internet
and I had to walk through that and this
was 1994 early 95 and so did I
anticipate you know fast forward to
today and and the current version of it
no it has been one foot in front of the
other and I think that that is true for
most businesses where you kind of
proceed adaptively its step by step you
figure it out you have a success and
then you kind of double down on that
success and you figure out what what
else you can do what customers want
another great message I think is
important you think big and you act
small I think Jeff had to think big to
some extent right he left his
high-paying job he drove across the
country he was able to raise a million
dollars for his business startup that's
because he had some kind of vision for
what this could become it's not like
we're just gonna throw up a website and
see what happens right he's not leaving
his job for that he's not getting
investors for that could he have
predicted that he would be the world's
wealthiest person to have over 100
billion dollars in a net worth maybe not
maybe that was beyond his scope but he
had a bigger vision for what he wanted
to do and he's gonna start small he's
gonna do everything himself he's gonna
pack boxes is gonna do all the
nitty-gritty stuff and not just be the
visionary only think big act small let's
go to rule number five find your calling
ever since I was five years old that's
when Neil Armstrong stepped onto the
surface of the Moon I've been
kind of passionate about space rockets
rocket engines space travel I became a
science fiction reader and I've always
known that I wanted to you know do
something having to do with space and
I've spent a lot of time thinking about
it for really almost my whole life and
that's one of the things you guys will
find that you have passions and having a
passion is a gift I think we all have
passions and you don't get to choose
them they pick you but you have to be
alert to them you have to be looking for
them and when you find your passion it's
a fantastic gift for you because it
gives you direction it gives you purpose
you could have a job or you can have a
career or you can have a calling and the
best thing is to have a calling and if
you find your passion you'll have that
and all your work won't feel like work
to you that last sentence was critical
all your work won't feel like work to
you you have to enjoy the process if you
are starting something just trying to
reach a goal just trying to be a
millionaire just trying to hit some
arbitrary target but you don't actually
enjoy the work you're gonna fail you
will fail it's great to have a goal and
say I'm gonna do whatever it takes but
if you don't actually enjoy a good chunk
of that work then you're never gonna
make and that's why most entrepreneurs
fail you have to do the work that
doesn't feel like work
even if it doesn't even make sense how
it's gonna work out at some point just
trust that the dots will align in your
future that's how it actually works
let's go to rule number six be nimble
and robust the thing for companies is
you need to be if you nibble and robust
so you need to be able to take a punch
and you also need to be quick and and
and and innovative and and doing new
things at a high speed that's that's the
best defense against the future and you
have to always be leaning into the
future if you're if you're leaning away
from the future the future is gonna win
every time never ever ever lean away
from the future it's a great point it's
also how you win against a big
competition the big composition is slow
and fat and lazy and you can win not off
your reputation on if you're experienced
not off of your history not after your
brand name you win because you're faster
and because you care more
let's go to rule number seven be
long-term oriented I ask everybody to
not think in two to three-year
timeframes but to think in five to
seven-year timeframes to not think about
when somebody says to me congratulate
samus on on a good quarter which is a
very common thing to say you meet
somebody they're being nice they looked
at your financial results for the
quarters of a good quarter I say thank
you but what I'm thinking to myself is
that quarter all that those quarterly
results were actually pretty much fully
baked about three years ago and so like
today I'm working on you know a quarter
that is gonna happen in 2020 not next
quarter next quarter for all practical
purposes is done already and it's
probably been done for a couple of years
and so if you start to think that way
it changes how you spend your time how
you plan where you put your energy and
and your ability to look around corners
gets better so many things improve if
you can take a long term by the way it's
not natural for humans so it's a it's a
discipline that you have to build the
the kind of you know get rich slowly
schemes are not big sellers on
infomercials you know it's and so that's
something that you have to sort of steel
yourself for discipline and teach
over time I think this is a really hard
message for entrepreneurs to take on
especially in the early stages of a
business because you can't wait five
years or something to happen you know
there are their realities of you wanting
to pay your bills and get by and have to
leave your job and have something that
you can really build up and succeed with
I think especially the early stages it's
good to have a healthy balance where yes
you have this big vision you have a plan
you know what you want to accomplish you
know where you want to be in five years
ten years even beyond and I need to do
something right now to make money you
know and I need to provide great
customer service and take advantage of
immediate opportunities in front of me
combining both those things especially
the early stages to get you to the point
where you have enough money coming in
that you can only think about the future
and where you want to go and not be so
concerned about the immediate but when
you're starting off now I think the
danger is too many people only see in
the immediate they're only thinking
about maybe not even next quarter
thinking about the next week which is
necessary just for survival and it's
important let's find a little bit of
time and that percentage increases over
time from you know 5% 10% 20% 25% you
keep increasing that percentage of time
of how forward-thinking your ideas and
your actions are moving on rule number
eight is choose a life of adventure you
can choose we all get to choose our life
stories and it's the choices that define
us not our gifts everybody in this room
has many gifts I have many gifts you can
never be proud of your gifts because
their gifts they were given to you you
might be you know tall or you might be
really good at math or you might be
extremely beautiful or handsome or you
know there are there many gifts and you
can only be proudly of your choices
because those are the things that you
are that you're that you are acting on
and one of the most important choices
that each of us has and you know this
just as well as I do is you can choose a
life of ease and comfort or you can
choose a life of service and adventure
and when you're 80 which one of those
things you think you're going to be more
proud of you're gonna be more proud of
having chosen a life of service or
adventure I think most people don't
just wake up and choose to be mediocre
or choose to be easy I think it's part
of our language and part of what we do
naturally as humans
I like the label of adventure though I
think if you were to ask yourself right
now what does a life of adventure look
like for me service and adventure what
does that look like today a month in a
year like what a month what are the
activities that lead to a life of
service and adventure if you ask
yourself that question right now you'll
start to come up with different
activities a different way of living a
different mindset different tasks you
should be doing to fulfill that dream
instead of the one that you're currently
doing which is really of ease and
comfort so low that point thank you Jeff
let's round it up
let's keep moving rule number nine find
allies what motivates me when times are
rough you know I find if I'm stressed
about something it's usually because I'm
not doing anything about it and so if
I'm stressed about something I've
transferred why am i stressed I'm
listening to my body as a signal that
I'm that something is awry and then I
find that the stress goes away the
second I take the first step of you
identify the source of the stress why am
I stressed about this what's going on
and then you know talk to somebody about
it find in a find allies you know I
would say that if you can find friends
who are interested in similar things or
want to help you solve a problem problem
solving is is inspiring for me all by
itself I have as long as I have allies
there's nothing more fun than getting in
a room with a group of inventors and
saying look here's the problem let's
invent a solution to it and as soon as
you start doing that I find that it
turns from something that might create
stress into something that creates fun
it's a really good point and I think you
can divide your allies into work and
business allies entrepreneur allies and
personal family friends kind
allies if the project you're dealing
with the problem the stress is coming
from your business how do I grow how do
i market how do I get my new product out
there your friends and family might be
able to be empathetic but they can't
give you strategies specific advice
because they don't know how to solve
that problem and so whether you have a
mastermind group or whether you have
some people you can call on that can
help you it could be really helpful and
then on the other side having the
friends and family having somebody close
to you who can deal with just the ups
and downs who if you feel that about
yourself are down or some tragedy
happened to be able to bounce that off
and not be isolated alone all the time
you know for me my wife Nina is is
fantastic at that if I need to bring
something up she's the one that I'll
talk to you about more personal stuff in
my mastermind group and some key mentors
and people that I talked to on the
business side are always there for me
when I need help and input so I think
find those allies being able to have
business allies and personal allies can
be really beneficial let's finish it off
with rule number 10 empower people on
the Internet today you know two kids in
their dorm room can reinvent an industry
that's how how it could because you
don't you the heavy lifting
infrastructure is in place for that
today two kids their dorm room can't do
anything interesting in space you know
you could build a CubeSat there's not
that much interesting about cube chess
and the that may change but right now
there's just you need there are certain
laws of physics and certain things you
need size for and things need to be big
we need to be able to put big things in
space at low cost and so if I'm 80 years
old and I can say to myself that Blue
Origin did the heavy lifting you know ky
using my Amazon winnings to do a new
piece of heavy lifting infrastructure
which is low-cost access to space
vehicles have to be reusable you can't
throw them away throw away space
vehicles every time you're never gonna
lower the cost so we're trying to lower
the price of admission into space so
that thousands of entrepreneurs can then
do amazing surprising things nobody and
they drive that much just nobody in 95
predicted
snapchat you know it's like I can't
predict for you what amazing
entrepreneurs brilliant amazing
entrepreneurs will do in space but I
know if I give them low-cost access to
space some brilliant you know 22 year
old is gonna figure it out it's one of
those things about what companies get
sustainable it's those that provide
platforms on upon which others can build
if you Amazon's power others empower
others to do things so AWS is like that
Kindle direct publishing is like that
our third-party selling businesses like
that fulfil up by Amazon is like that
every time you figure out some way of
providing tools and services that
empower other people to deploy their
creativity you're really onto something
so first off I'm really grateful to Jeff
Bezos and Amazon for empowering
entrepreneurs like me through create
space to write books the top ten rules
of success is to create space it's an
Amazon company and that's where it's
being sold and I think whatever mission
you're on it's important to empower
others to help you on that mission so
not every idea has to be through you
other people can help support the cause
if you can't be such a control freak
egomaniac that is only as you it's that
the mission is bigger than everything
else and so someone like Martin Luther
King wasn't on the frontlines all the
time but he's shown the light on people
who are doing great things and empowered
them and inspired them to do more I
think this works also on a micro level
so it's not just about the mission and
the big picture thing it also works on a
small level the people on your team are
you micromanaging every single decision
or can you empower them to make
decisions on their own and help your
company achieve even better results as
well
so thank you guys so much for watching I
love to know which was your favorite
rule what did you learn the most in this
video and how are you going to
immediately apply it somehow to your
life or your business my favorite rule
was rule number two which was do hard
things it's a constant reminder that I
need to do more do more difficult
challenges not get comfortable not get
lazy not continue to coast on my talent
but push harder constantly to do bigger
things I don't know what did you learn
from this video leave it in the comments
below I'm excited to see what you have
to say now I made this video because no
leaf clover 830 asked me to if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next check out the link in the
description you can go and cast your
vote on the request line I also want to
give a quick shout out to Tim Schmoyer
from video creators Tim thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and for being one of the
quotes on the back and for posting it to
your Instagram channel I really really
appreciate the support man and I'm so
glad you enjoyed the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much loved I'll see you soon
you have to back up and find the right
time horizon for what you're trying to
do but you know at Amazon we probably do
most of our things we expect that to get
some results in sort of five six seven
eight years but we find a lot of our you
know other companies that compete
against us in various ways
they're often trying to get things done
in you know two or three years and so we
can do things that you know if you if
you if everything has to work in two to
three years then that limits what you
can do if you give yourself the
breathing room to say okay I'm okay if
it takes seven years all of a sudden you
have way more opportunities i've always
been focused when I was in Montessori
School the Montessori School teacher
told my mom that I wouldn't switch tasks
and they and they got me to switch tasks
by picking me up including my chair and
just moving me to the new task station
I've gotten a little better about that
over the years but it's still task
switching is still a problem for me
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people
passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your it's supposed
to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten roaster
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details